casey musgraves is gracing the cover of
l and getting candid about her divorce
from her ex-husband
rustin kelly i love being at home
hanging out with my horse hanging out
with my husband you know
and that always gives me some ideas but
that's all changed
in the june july issue the singer admits
that her marriage took a turn for the
worse once the kova 19 pandemic hit
keeping the two isolated at home
together for months
early last year she said quote i could
have coasted for another couple of years
noting that she was just not paying
attention to my feelings or not really
dealing with some things
and the extended time at home led casey
to question herself
like why did i make these decisions how
did i get here
how can i prevent myself from getting
there again why do i keep choosing the
same kind of people
she added that in many ways she felt
like she was on top of the world in her
career
but in her personal life casey felt like
she was dying inside
quote i was crumbling i was sad i felt
lonely
i felt broken the country singer also
said she comes from a family full of
long marriages
so she had a hard time grappling with
the reality of her own marriage coming
to an end
but casey's having fun with it now
posting a photo from the shoe on
instagram with the caption
legs longer than my marriage when it
rains it pours
but you didn't even
and fans get ready for some new music
because casey tells the mac she's
putting
all these emotions in her next songs it
would be strange if i didn't acknowledge
what happened in my life creatively
but it is scary to be like i'm about to
share my most personal thoughts about me
about this other person about a union
that i had with someone
i was just coasting never really going
anywhere
this is not the first time casey has
poured her feelings out through her
music
her album golden hour was inspired by
rustin as she told et
at the 2018 cmas i think the whole
record's about him you know he inspires
true he inspired this entire album and
the second that i met him my world just
opened up and i feel like i bloomed
like in a lot of ways i kind of had this
little metamorphosis of self
and i thank him a lot for that and i
look up to him a lot as a creator too
casey may have reflected on her past but
she's moved
on from her marriage girl i've got to
live life i need to like live life
living life with her new boyfriend dr
gerald onoha
a physician based in nashville in april
a source told e.t that casey and gerald
are dating
and adds she's into him the source adds
she likes that he's a doctor
and not very involved in the
entertainment industry but he also gets
it
it's really a beautiful time in my life
full of lots of change
and you know i just want to keep doing
what i'm doing